let's go next to our caller from the 319
area code who's calling today from 319.
hey david um i'm going to call myself
tim
um and i'm part of the yang gang here
and i'm curious to see what your opinion
is on this um
i'm actually uh a little different from
the yang gang
because i think that actually looking at
the different candidates that
uh mr yang is supporting across the
board including
um and i'll encourage everybody to look
these guys up um alex morse an amazing
candidate
and also dr robbie goldstein uh and then
another amazing candidate
um there in massachusetts and so um i'm
seeing um
he's being even to my opinion being more
effective
being outside of kind of being in this
um
uh outside political role instead of
being on the inside and so
because of that i'm actually starting to
think as like
a very proud card-carrying member of the
yang gang
um that he actually might not be as
effective in a presidential role
and instead might be more effective in a
sort of like
semi-political role and so i want to see
what your take on that
is um considering that you know um you
look at donna hyman
and uh texas uh just 31 she's an amazing
candidate
um who won her primary there and i would
love to see her go on and win so i don't
see what your take is on that
i think it's completely reason i mean so
okay here's the thing about andrew yang
one of the critiques of andrew yang
during the campaign
i mean again remember he never pulled
more than like two percent so we're
talking about
things in a sort of abstract sense but
one of the critiques of andrew yang
during the campaign
was that maybe he had too much of a sort
of consultancy approach to politics
where everything is
you know it's just like project
management and it's sort of like
the tainted or influenced by
his entrepreneurial background there
were some people who were critical of
him along those lines
the reality is that that works really
well in what you're talking about which
is
he has a sort of fixed amount of
political capital right now
and you can be strategic about saying
okay
he's going to get behind alex morris by
the way alex morris was on on my show
last week
and this other person he could influence
people in this way i think that
andrew yang's strengths work
very naturally in building coalition
and supporting other candidates
mobilizing people doing interviews and
getting people aware of some of these
candidates so i think what you're saying
makes a lot of sense
yeah and so um i guess i'm just coming
in from the standpoint of
um personally i guess i see
his support for a four-day work week
being a much more
palatable policy and if
i think that he actually might be more
effective and pushing
say um you know biden or if not biden
then
um some of the other candidates for
whoever comes after biden
on say a four day work week which i
think would um
you know i think uh that's where i stand
anyway if the four day work week just
um needs to be i think here so anyway
especially
in the coved era where it seems like
everybody's working around the clock and
yeah so anyway thanks for your input all
right thank you for the call great to
hear from you